bonsoir audition publique c'est le
rendez vous en direct comme tous les
lundis pendant une heure du débat de la
confrontation des infos aussi une heure
avec notre invité aujourd'hui qui est
laurent nunez bonsoir ans sur internet
et à l'intérieur on va parler de
l'organisation des élections municipales
ça approche c'est dans trois semaines le
premier tour le financement des cultes
il en est beaucoup question le système
de retraite spécial pour les policiers
les gendarmes parce que ils ont droit à
une dérogation
et puis la menace que représentent les
piles emile connoy coronavirus on va
parler de tout cela on va retrouver dans
quelques instants aussi mes consoeurs
des chaînes parlementaires également un
député et une sénatrice qui viendront
débattre avec vous et puis il très rare
du figaro qui vous posera ses questions
à lui tout à l'heure en fin d'émission
sans oublier les questions où les
réactions de téléspectateurs via twitter
et le hashtag audition publique ou sur
lefigaro.fr
on va commencer par le corona virus
puisque l'organisation mondiale de la
santé a indiqué tout à l'heure que le
monde devait se préparer à une
éventuelle pandémie
pour l'instant en france il ya eu deux
cas mortels
en italie c'est beaucoup plus grave pour
l'instant en cas d'extension de
l'épidémie
est ce que la mesure qui consisterait à
fermer les frontières est possible ou
pas d'abord en france nous avons une
simple en situation épidémique
il ya eu il ya eu 12 cas donc dix
personnes qui ont été qui sont guéris
qui avait été prise en charge
et puis deux autres cas une personne qui
est actuellement hospitalisé et qui va
bien et puis on a eu un décès au titre
du coronavirus un seul décès dans ces
douze personnes concernées nombre en
france on n'est pas en situation
d'épidémie servi à un moment où le virus
vous échappez se répand sauf que sans
aucun n'a pas de frontières donc au cas
où est ce que la possibilité de fermer
les frontières
c'est à l'étude cette mesure n'est pas
envisagé parce que c'est une mesure qui
par exemple n'est pas recommandé par
l'organisation mondiale de la santé vous
savez il n'ya pas que des frontières
terrestres et des frontières aériennes
maritimes puisque la question a été
posée pour l'italie la frontière franco
italienne
on peut très bien accéder au territoire
national par la suisse par l'autriche et
par de nombreuses autres pays dans
l'espace
libre qui est l'espace schengen jours
c'est un concept qui cette question
n'est pas à l'ordre du jour parce que ce
n'est pas une mesure qui est efficace et
les paroles et où elle est complètement
exclue elle n'est pas à l'ordre du jour
allaient complètement exclu à ce stade
en revanche se prépare est effectivement
évidemment une éventuelle épidémie
le ministre des solidarités et de la
santé l'a rappelé encore il ya il y à
quelques quelques minutes seulement le
ministre l'a rappelé nous nous y
préparons le premier ministre a organisé
une réunion de ministres d'hier à
laquelle le ministre de l'intérieur a
participé christophe castaner évidemment
la france se prépare à une éventuelle
épidémie c'est le travail du
gouvernement
vous savez que le ministre des
solidarités de la santé a annoncé que
par exemple qu'il y aurait 100 8
établissements de santé en capacité
d'accueillir d'éventuelles malades
petite parenthèse rapide si la france
devait décider de fermer ses frontières
est ce qu'elle pourrait prendre la
décision seule ou ça dépend aussi des
accords genyen ça dépend évidemment des
accords de schengen auquel vous pourrez
pas décidé s'il existe un certain nombre
de dérogations qui sont prévus dans des
cas très précis et pour laquelle la
commission recommande évidemment qu'il y
ait une concertation entre étant là ce
serait le cas si c'est pour le corps ou
des virus ou des histoires de santé ça
entrerait dans ce cadre là on ne peut le
faire que dans des cas très précis très
précis on va maintenant accueillir mes
concerts des chaînes parlementaires
comme traduite mixer n'avons soir et
brigitte boucher de lcp assemblée
nationale dont soir et c'est eux qui
commandent toujours à propos du corps
une avion oui on ya parlé du coran
navire russe le principal problème
aujourd'hui pour la france c'est le sud
est et les alpes maritimes les élus
d'ailleurs m adapte des alpes-maritimes
christian estrosi ou encore eric ciotti
demande un plan d'urgence et plus de
contrôle des frontières qu'est ce que
vous leur répondez allez-vous les voir
je viens de le dire à l'instant ce cette
fermeture des frontières n'aurait pas
d'impact à mettre au défi par contre ce
qui se passe et c'est vrai aussi dans
les alpes-maritimes
évidemment que nous avons des
établissements de santé qui sont tout à
fait opérationnel pour accueillir
d'éventuels patients mais encore une
fois nous n'en sommes pas là le
gouvernement a pris un certain nombre de
mesures extrêmement importantes dont la
sensibilisation de l'ensemble du secteur
des trois secteurs de de médecine qu'ils
s'agissent de l'hôpital le secteur de la
médecine en ville ou du secteur médico
social
donc il ya énormément d'informations qui
a été diffusé pour détecter au plus vite
d'éventuels kayes pour mieux pouvoir les
confiner c'est dans ce sens que j le
gouvernement ailières marine le pen a
estimé que le gouvernement aurait dû
interdire les vols en provenance de
chine qu'est ce que vous en pensez ce
que c'est une option envisageable
écoutez non c'est pas une option
envisageable certaines compagnies l'ont
fait vous le savez donc il y a encore
des vols qui des vols vers la chine est
depuis la chine mais touche son contrôle
et à l'arrivée donc les personnes
reçoivent des recommandations
extrêmement précises ya un accueil qui
est organisée dans chaque aéroport avec
des pelles de tous les vols qui
proviennent de chillon donne un certain
nombre de recommandations notamment pour
les personnes qui viennent des autres
dites à risque en chine où on leur donne
un certain nombre d'informations et
notamment pour les personnes qui
viennent des zones à risque il ya des
routes des recommandations précises qui
sont données notamment sur les contacts
qu'elle peut avoir des masques de
protection également leur sont donnés
donc toutes les mesures sont prises en
matière d'information est-ce qu'il peut
y avoir des conséquences pour les
campagnes municipales que vous j'étais
comme au ministère de l'intérieur
est ce qu'il faut par human annuler des
meetings des rassemblements la question
se pose absolument pas pour l'instant
nous ne sommes pas en situation
épidémique
vous avez raison de souligner que ce
type de mesure est parfois envisagé
d'interdire certains rassemblements
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui s'est fait en
italie
le carnaval de locarno voilà mais ces
mesures ne sont pas envisagées encore
une fois nous ne sommes pas dans une
situation épidémique à ce stade vous
l'avez dit olivier ferrand a mobilisé
des hôpitaux d'indifférence aujourd'hui
sans luttes hôpitaux vous à l'intérieur
quel dispositif vous avez prévu mais le
dispositif le la crise est gérée d'abord
par le musée solidarité de la santé et
c'est une c'est une séductrice qui gère
aussi de manière interministériel s'il
devait y avoir une épidémie est
évidemment les préfets sont pleinement
mobilisés sur ce sujet le ministre la
question se pose pas mal je répond
précisément à votre question les préfets
sont totalement mobilisées évidemment
sur le susie éventuelle d'une épidémie
c'est l'heure c'est leur job
ils savent le faire il ya des plans
qu'ils existent et qui sont déclenchées
si jamais ça devait être greffé sur ses
plans sur quels critères on décide de
confiner une ville par exemple écouter
honnêtement la question ne se pose pas
ça n'est qu'en situation d'épidémie
qu'on se pose ce genre de questions les
plans le prévoyant faire ça vite mais
pour l'instant il ne s'agit pas ne
s'agit pas d'affoler tous ceux qui nous
regardent ce soit nous ne sommes pas en
situation d'épidémie encore une fois
qu'ils sachent simplement que le
gouvernement se prépare sur tous les
aspects et surtout sur le dispositif
d'accueil médical dans les
établissements
justement un bus en provenance d'italie
a été immobilisé en gare de lyon
perrache à lyon
est-ce que vous avez suivi la situation
de près il s'avère que finalement il
semblerait que le chauffeur ont tous
craignaient quelqu'un à virus ne l'a pas
mais cela montre quand même l'étendue de
la psychose ça montre surtout la
réactivité je pense des pouvoirs publics
dans cette situation que évidemment avec
christophe castaner nous avons suivi de
près comme vous l'imaginez le chauffeur
a fait l'objet
deux tests qui ont permis de lever un
certain nombre de doutes et le
confinement a pu être levé du bus
ça s'est aussi produit cet après midi
pour une autre raison dans un
commissariat de police comme la presse
en a fait état donc le commissariat du
xiiie arrondissement
voilà on est extrêmement réactif pour
essayer d'être toujours d'identifier
toujours le cas le hall ce qu'on appelle
le patient zéro c'est de savoir d'où
vient éventuellement le virus ce qui
manque aux italiens d'ailleurs pour
prendre et qu'est ce qui les a
contraints à prendre des mesures
concernant beaucoup plus radicale voilà
pour ce sujet on va parler maintenant
d'autres choses ce matin la mise la
justice nicole belloubet a parlé de
djihadistes qui serait libéré bientôt 43
djihadistes incarcéré en font ce qu'ils
seraient libérés
cette année donc en 2020 selon nicole
belloubet comment vos services de
renseignement vont-ils les suivre à leur
sortie de prison
alors effectivement ces quelques
dizaines qui vont être libérés cette
année puis l'année prochaine 60
prochaine exactement
donc nous avons mis en place un
dispositif de suivi qui a lieu déjà en
milieu pénitentiaire je le rappeler ce
qu'est ce gouvernement qui a créé un
service central du renseignement
pénitentiaire qui permet d'assurer un
suivi extrêmement précis d'un certain
nombre d'individus service central du
renseignement pénitentiaire qui était un
bureau qui avait été créée sous le
quinquennat de monsieur hollande et que
nous avons transformé en service qui
travaille avec tous les services de
renseignement dont la direction générale
de la sécurité intérieure qui suit de
très près les individus qu'on appelle du
haut du spectre et tous les services
travaillent ensemble et il y a à chaque
sortie de détenus il ya évidemment des
mesures de suivi qui sont mises en place
dont il ne m'appartient pas pour les
raisons évidentes de confidentialité de
les révéler bien sûr mais évidemment des
mesures individuelles de suivi et
j'insiste également sur une mesure que
nous utilisons dans la dans la majorité
des cas pour le suivi des détenus ce
sont les mesures administratives
individuel de contrôle les fameuses me
casse pour parler en abrégé que nous
utilisons qui permet d'obliger un
certain nombre d'années
à venir régulièrement pointé en
commissariat de police ou gendarmerie et
à ne pas pouvoir se déplacer librement
dans certains périmètres justement c'est
une mesure extrêmement utile de suivi
des détenus des détenus
radicaliser radicaliser alors quand
elles se présentent pas évidemment gamme
justement sur à des pédales celui de
flavien moreau c'est le premier
jihadiste qui a été libéré en ce début
d'année les personnels pénitentiaires
dont estimait que lorsqu'il a été libéré
il était encore radicaliser il était
encore dangereux
concrètement comment vous le suivez et
puis avec vous les moyens de suivre on
dit il faudrait au moins 20 personnes
pour le suivre à 24 ans maintenant ça
dépend ce que d'abord je comprendrais
que en plus en tant qu'ancien directeur
général de la seigneurie teinte alors je
ne peux pas détaillé ce qu'un dispositif
de suivi le disposent les vingt
personnes c'est un dispositif de suivi
physique ça veut dire des fonctionnaires
de police qui en permanence sur vers un
objectif
ça n'est pas le seule façon de
surveillants dans le fief de savoir
comment ils se dépêchent évidemment
évidemment on h 24 les autres mais non
mais je suis en train de vous expliquer
que le suivi n'est pas forcément ce
n'est pas forcément un suivi h 24
physique ça peut l'être ponctuellement
on peut utiliser d'autres techniques
vous savez qu'il ya une loi de 2015 qui
autorise l'utilisation d'un certain
nombre de techniques de renseignement
quand il ya un risque qu'une menace
et puis il ya les fameuses me casse donc
monsieur phal veulent le l'individu que
vous avez cités flavia morrow fait
l'objet d'une vie cassé donc il est
astreint à aller pointer un certain
nombre de fois au commissariat ou en
brigade de gendarmerie
mais voilà nous assurons un contrôle
effectif et surtout ce qu'il faut avoir
l'esprit c'est que ça n'est pas parce
que des individus ont purgé leur peine
du fait de fait à kara qualifiés de
terroristes que lorsqu'ils sortent de
prison ne sont pas suivies par les
services d'ordre il ya un suivi effectif
juste mais alors oui rachida dati
l'ancienne ministre de la justice se dit
qu'il faudrait étendre la rétention de
sûreté à ces individus dangereux elle
l'a fait adopter en 2008
est ce qu'il faudrait changer la loi
justement elle s'applique aux jihadistes
d'abord la rétention
de sûreté ne joue elle vient heurter
quand même en principe un peu
constitutionnel si voulez vous avez
purgé votre peine
la rétention de sûreté elle ne peut être
mise en place que lorsque l'individu
présente réellement une menace et une
menace grave donc elle cette mesure ne
pourra jouer pour un nombre limité
d'individus elle ne peut relever que
d'une décision de justice elle ne peut
relever que d'un juge judiciaire qui
aurait que la condamnation initiale la
prévoit c'est comme ça que ça fonctionne
dans les rares cas où ça existe et ça
fonctionne ça ne fonctionne que dans un
nombre très très très dur et me dire
quoi ce que propose ce que propose
rachida dati comme ce que proposent les
républicains en matière de suivi de la
radicalisation notamment en prison je
les renvoie ce qu'ils ont fait avant
2012 où aucune mesure n'a été prise pour
les détenus qui étaient radicaliser vous
savez comme je lé rappeler encore
récemment l'assemblée nationale la
radicalisation en milieu carcéral
elle n'est pas née en 2012 avec
l'élection du président françois
hollande elle avait lieu bien avant et
aucune mesure concrète réelle non et le
communautarisme le séparatisme qui sont
aussi au coeur des sujets puisque la
semaine dernière le président de la
république était à mulhouse emmanuel
macron va recevoir des responsables
associatifs et débat est loin d'être
clos
oui effectivement et l'opposition de
droite puisque vous en parliez dénonce
le fait que le gouvernement n'aille pas
assez loin pour lutter contre le
salafisme cette mosquée fermée depuis
2010 est est ce que ça veut dire que
c'est eux qui exagère le phénomène ou
est ce que ça veut dire qu'il y aura
d'autres fermetures à venir de mosquée
d'abord d'abord il faut bien il faut
bien re situer les choses dans leur
contexte vous savez depuis maintenant
2013 on lutte dans ce pays contre la
radicalisation violents notamment qui
peut déboucher sur le terrorisme c'est
toutes les mesures qui ont été prises
qui ont commencé sous le quinquennat
précédent que nous avons renforcé
d'augmenter les moyens des services de
renseignement les moyens juridiques les
moyens budgétaires la création d'un
fichier de suivi des individus
radicalisés
les groupes qui se tiennent dans chaque
département animé par les préfets et qui
font que nous avons une action forte les
services de renseignements qui nous ont
permis depuis la fin de l'année 2013 de
d'avoir déjoué soixante et un attentat
dans ce pays dont 32 depuis 2010
depuis que nous sommes aux assauts les
investissements n'oublions pas cette
action de lutte contre le terrorisme
qu'on élude un peu rapidement je trouve
et qui est exemplaire de ce café nescafé
de ce qu'a souhaité que nous mettions en
oeuvre le président bak ont notamment ce
travail
décloisonner des services de
renseignements mais j'en ai été un
acteur je sais de quoi je parle
alors que cette mosquée cette mosquée
est fermé depuis 2010 7 c au titre de la
loi sylt au titre de la loi d'octobre
2010 est de lutte contre le terrorisme
pour des motifs terroristes mais votre
chiffre n'est pas tout à fait exact
puisque en réalité et c'est ce que nous
faisons dans le cadre de l'action que
nous menons contre le séparatisme et je
vais y venir parce que maintenant
l'action que nous avons lancée à titre
expérimental d'ailleurs dans quinze
quartier depuis février 2018 depuis
février 2018 déjà nous l'avons nous
avons lancé cette action de lutte contre
les phénomènes séparatisme dans certains
quartiers où on va considérer que la loi
de dieu est supérieur finalement aux
lois de la république et il en découle
tout un tas de conséquences en matière
de discrimination matière d'accès aux
services publics en matière de
scolarisation des enfants et nous avons
demandé dans ses 15 quartiers et puis
nous avons généralisé cette action
depuis la fin de l'année 2019 le
ministre a adressé une circulaire vise
de l'intérieur à l'ensemble des préfets
pour que des contrôles aient lieu
partout partout dans les secteurs où en
clair le rôle qu'ils sont frappés par
l'espère que ça veut dire que dans ce
cadre là pardon je termine oui mais
sinon on parle que des 15 quartiers pour
ne parler que des 15 quartiers qui que
nous avons expérimenté depuis février
2018 ce sont quinze lieux de culte qui
ont été fermées et la belgique
oui valérie pécresse la présidente de la
région ile de france
elle demande de mettre fin au
financement des mosquées par des
étrangers comme on le fait pour les
partis politiques sont ni personne et à
qui financerait est ce que c'est une
piste à suivre pour vous non d'abord il
faut voir que tout est dans tout le jeu
vous parlait donc de la lutte contre le
séparatisme que nous venons de que nous
venons de lancer qui va constituer donc
à cibler nos contrôles de droit commun
en utilisant les polices administratives
spéciales des préfets les pouvoirs des
procureurs quand il ya des infractions
pénales pour partout rappeler que seule
la loi de la république prévost et bien
à la loi de melaky sens su mener cette
action nous avons besoin pour mener
cette action d'avoir comme interlocuteur
un islam qui est structuré et un islam
qui soit dégagée qu'ils soient dégagées
est-ce que voilà est-ce qu'il faut agir
j'y viens je viens il faut que ce soit
un islam qui soit détachée des
ingérences étrangères
l'intérêt que nous ayons un partenaire
qui soit solide et fiable c'est ce que
le ministre de l'intérieur a demandé au
conseil français du culte est à dire les
hululements étrangers le président l'a
annoncé à bourtzwiller il y aura des
mesures législatives qui seront prévus
et qui prévoiront un contrôle de d'un
certain nombre de financements étrangers
dans des conditions qu'un texte de loi
définira mais il y aura un contrôle
contrôle ça veut dire déjà en avoir
connaissance
et le cas échéant pouvoir s'y opposer
lorsque ce financement voilà je
comprenais que je ne peux pas vous en
dire plus le président a lancé a annoncé
qu'il y aurait une mesure législative
sur ces sujets la réflexion est en cours
je ne peux pas vous en dire plus mais
voilà je voulais répondre à votre
question mais en restituant la mesure
dans dans l'ensemble du contexte qu'ils
font je t'en rends pour être très clair
il n'y a pas d'interdiction de
financement étranger des mosquées il n'y
en a pas écoutés il n'y aura a priori
actuellement actuellement il n'y a aucun
contrôle
il n'y a aucune déclaration les choses
vont être rationalisée sur le contrôle
puis autorisation ok on va parler
maintenant des policiers vos employés
aux fonctionnaires table oui justement
où en est la promesse à mi mandat cette
promesse d' emmanuel macron de créer dix
mille postes de policiers d'ici 2022
alors cette promesse elle est honorée
donc puisque nous avons déjà recruté
dont 4500 policiers gendarmes et puis
sommes à la moitié du chemin est donc
les recrutements se poursuivront sur
2020 2021 et 2022 donc pour poursuivre
cet effort de reconstitution des forces
de l'ordre qui avaient été sérieusement
amoché entre guillemets avant 2012 sous
le quinquennat donc de nicolas sarkozy
ou douze mille cinq cents emplois
avaient été supprimés selon nous payons
encore aujourd'hui les conséquences dit
oui
christophe castaner à nier qu'il y est
une étude pour encadrer les
autorisations de films et de diffuser
sur les réseaux sociaux les les
policiers lors d'interpellations ou dans
les manifestations est ce que cette
étude existe ou pas sachant que la dgpn
qui la direction générale de la police
nationale
elle a dit qu'il y avait une étude l'a
dit à mediapart je crois je suis dit
fais ce que je peux dire c'est que il ya
une demande d'un certain nombre
d'organisations syndicales d'avoir de
permettre le floutage des policiers qui
sont filmés sur la voie publique dans
l'exercice de leurs missions qu est-ce
qui cette demande on peut comprendre
elle est légitime
vous avez parfois des images qui sont
balancés sur les réseaux sociaux des
policiers qui sont parfois menacées je
le rappelais au sénat la semaine
dernière parfois jusqu'à leur domicile
je suis tassé diffusion d'image donc il
n'ya pas d'étude
donc sauf qu'à sa mère l'a dit je
confirme évidemment ce qu'a dit la
direction générale de la police
nationale à mediapart a dit dès midi il
n'y a pas d'étude il ya pas de projet de
floutage des vidéos qui sont tournés sur
la voie publique chp et voilà je peux
des cordiers vandriesse a presque pas de
problème avec les directions contraires
moi je ne confirme pas ce que vous dites
je ne sais pas ce qu'a dit la direction
générale de la police nationale à
médiapart ce que je peux vous dire c'est
qu'on n'a pas détruit six cylindres à
passer de commandes et après moi j'étais
aussi un directeur général d'un service
de police rien n'empêche un service de
réfléchir à une question juridique quand
il est interposé que ce soit officiel
soit une commande très bien moi je ne
sais pas se faire dépasser dans ce cas
là en tout cas nous n'avons rien leurs
études à eux c'est un sujet que nous
avons en tête parce que c'est une
préoccupation les organisations
syndicales mais il n'a pas cette
question n'est pas à l'ordre du jour
on va parler surveillance au salon de
l'agriculture 2020 eric deroo a été
interpellé et mis en garde leurs 2 g des
jo
le leader d'un gilet jaune a été donc
mis en garde à vue pendant la visite des
manuels macron jérôme rodriguez
interpellé dans les rues de lille à peu
près au même moment est-ce que les jets
les jaunes sont sous surveillance alors
être les noms les lions ne sont pas sous
surveillance jérôme rodriguez il a été
interpellé dans le cadre d'une
manifestation qui a été très violente et
maillet de nombreuses violences
nous avons encore eu des policiers qui
ont été blessées et il ya eu des
interpellations il ya eu des
dégradations de mobilier urbain de
commerce et les forces de l'ordre ont dû
encore une fois donc maintenir l'ordre
républicain et jérôme rodriguez il a été
interpellé dans ce cadre monsieur deux
roues et il était présent sur le salon
de l'agriculture je pense je crois
comprendre qu'il voulait approcher le
président de la république éric deroo
est quelqu'un qui a de nombreuses
reprises donc à organiser des
manifestations sans déclaration on voit
là les policiers ont constaté qu'il
était présent on peut penser qu'il
voulait aller au contact du président
d'ard c'était moi je ne connais pas un
président de la république j'ai fait
deux j'ai eu aussi à gérer des services
d'eau mais elle s'en remet à faire
passer qu'un sur ses intentions il n'a
pas été interpellé sur ses intentions il
a été contrôlé et il ya eu à ce moment
là et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs qu'il a
été placé en garde à vue un outrage une
rébellion et qui a été retenue contre
lui dans des conditions tout à fait
légale et réglementée
la police municipale est un des thèmes
de campagne et notamment à paris pour
les pour les municipales alors anne
hidalgo elle propose la création d'une
police municipale armée sans arme létale
déjà est-ce que c'est nécessaire une
police municipale
un pari gens qui à la préfecture de
police évidemment évidemment c'est
nécessaire d'avoir une police municipale
c'est vrai partout dans toutes les
villes est d'ailleurs une des réflexions
que nous avons avec christophe castaner
dans le cadre du livre blanc parce que
c'est aussi une demande des élus locaux
dans le cadre de la concertation nous
avons l'enjeu lancé c'est d'avoir une
police municipale qui assurent les
missions qui sont les siennes de la
tranquillité de la salubrité des
troubles de voisinage de manière à
dégager des charges et les forces de
police nationale de gendarmerie selon le
cas pour pouvoir leur permet de se
concentrer sur ce que sont les rails si
la lutte contre la délinquance des roses
donc oui une police municipale s'est
particulièrement précieux et à paris
mettant notamment à paris puisque les
polluent la police nationale effectue
beaucoup de missions qui dans une autre
ville relèverait de la peau les armes
ici pas le l'armement de la police
municipale relève ses principes de libre
administration des collectivités locales
le maire a la faculté de décider d'armé
ou pas sa police je pense qu à tignes et
je le dis à titre personnel donc
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'intérieur peut évidemment que les
policiers municipaux doivent être armés
évidemment on a vu dans le désert mais
la vue en janvier 2015
bien sûr avec des armes et à l' on a vu
en janvier 2015
une policière municipale victime d'un
acte terroriste l' arme létale c'est ce
qui permet également de patrouiller avec
la police nationale d'avoir des missions
conjointes et c'est ce qui permet
d'aller au devant de difficultés
d'exercer effectivement ces missions
donc à titre personnel je suis
évidemment favorable à ce que la syrie
déclare ainsi ses acolytes il faut
respecter le principe de lee byrne seule
réserve activités locales ce qui veut
dire qu'il nous serait difficile de
l'imposer
nous serons très officiel violeur pour
une police municipale armée parce que
sans ça sert à rien si elles épargnées
si elle n'est pas rare mais les
policiers peuvent être des cibles
il faut qu'ils puissent défendre ça
c'est important et pour réaliser leur
mission ils seront confrontés de plus en
plus sali le niveau de violence à
l'encontre des forces de l'ordre et des
personnes dépositaires de l'autorité
publique dont font partie les policiers
municipaux
c'est ce niveau de violence ne cesse
d'augmenter il faut que les un policier
municipal dont le dont la vie dont ils
seraient attenter à la vie doit pouvoir
se les fans alors c'était un enjeu des
municipales à paris
logique de disette à ben vous avez
conseillé agnès buzyn lors de sa
campagne à paris un quidam débuté vous
avez participé à une réunion sur la
sécurité est ce que c'est vraiment votre
rôle de ministre ce que vous ne prêtez
pas le flanc aux critiques de
l'opposition qui parle de mélange des
genres
non c'est pas un mélange des genres du
tout je suis aussi un homme politique je
suis certains ministres mais je suis un
homme politique c'est en tant qu'homme
politique que je suis allé j'ai
participé à une réunion de travail avec
agnès buzyn sur les questions de
sécurité
donc voilà je suis aussi un homme
politique on nous demande c'est
évidemment j'y suis allé tout seul
j'ai travaillé mon dossier tout seul et
voilà donc je sais ça le ce qu'il faut
regarder
je suis allé j'y suis allé parce que
j'ai un petit peu de compétences sur les
questions aussi de sécurité sur bastia
je suis allée comme homme politique si
un autre candidat vous demander vos
conseils vous iriez aussi je soutient
madame agnès buzyn qui est donc membre
de la république en marche quand je fais
partie de la république en marche donc
je soutiens évidemment les candidats de
mon parti ou ceux qui sont soutenus par
mon parti
merci talent merci brigitte et on va
accueillir maintenant les parlementaires
qui ont aussi des questions à vous poser
merci
car audition publique c'est aussi le
lieu où les parlementaires viennent
interpeller les ministres que vous
connaissez puisque vous rencontrez dans
vos hémicycle respectif et donc je vous
présentez nous accueillons nathalie
delattre
bonsoir vous à sénatrice mouvement
radical de gironde et ses fans peu
bonsoir vous êtes député pcf de
seine-saint-denis ont parlé d'islam tout
à l'heure c'est l'une des questions
d'ailleurs de nathalie delattre pour
commencer oui tout à fait je voulais
évoquer le communautarisme religieux ou
bien avec la nouvelle sémantique du
président de la république le
séparatisme religieux saluer d'abord le
fait qu'il est affirmé que c'était une
priorité
alors malheureusement il ya des
priorités tous les jours mais au moins
c'est fait il nous ne sommes plus dans
le déni politique je pense que vos
fonctions antérieures vous ont permis de
constater que le phénomène prenait de
l'ampleur alors comme j'ai pu l'évoquer
aux questions au gouvernement mercredi
dernier face à aux ministres castetner
j'ai quand même une crainte voir
malheureusement une certitude c'est que
le président se fourvoie comme ses
prédécesseurs c'est à dire qu' il va
rechercher un islam de france
c'est à dire une sémantique des frères
musulmans qui aujourd'hui nous parle de
la possibilité d'avoir un islam modéré
sur notre territoire
alors qu'en fait il s'agit bien
d'adapter un islam en france ce que
pratiquent des milliers de musulmans
dans le respect des lois de la
république et des principes de la
laïcité
donc par rapport à ça j'ai dû trois
petites questions
on va commencer par une en demandant au
cfcm de ce le musulman de s'organiser
est-ce qu'on n'est pas sur le fil quand
même de la loi de 1905 qui prône le fait
de ne pas que l'état ne s'ingère pas
dans les questions religieuses et quel
type effectivement d'organisation vous
parliez tout à l'heure je faisais
écouter du financement par exemple
aujourd'hui
l'organisation objectif d'organisation
répondre le ministre étranger notamment
le d'abord effectivement donc vous avez
raison de souligner qu'on s'attaque au
problème du séparatisme
c'est nous qui le faisons les premiers
ça n'a jamais été fait avant
donc il faut quand même le rappeler
puisque j'entends dire beaucoup de
choses des gens qui ont assez peu de
mémoire finalement sur ce que nous avons
lancée et encore une fois nous avons
expérimenté dans le quinze quartier
depuis février 2018 donc c'était
vraiment au tout début du quinquennat
et c'est une président de la république
il tenait particulièrement les classes
sur l'organisation de l'organisation se
demande pourquoi pourquoi nous avons
besoin d'avoir un islam structure est
d'abord parce que et vous l'avez rappelé
madame la sénatrice la plupart des
musulmans pratiquent leur foi dans des
conditions qui sont respectueuses des
lois françaises
et dans le respect de l'ordre public ce
qui est l'exigence que pose la loi de
1905 40 il l'exercice du libre culte à
tout
nous avons besoin dans ce pays d'avoir
des interlocuteurs structuré en matière
de culte musulman et de les avoir de
manière structurée notamment au niveau
départemental qui est l'échelon de base
comme vous le savez d'un autre pays et
qui est l'échelon au niveau duquel nous
luttons contre le séparatisme et la
radicalisation religieuse notamment
violente et nos préfets ont besoin
d'avoir des interlocuteurs qu'ils soient
structurées à ce niveau là et c c'est
pour cela qu'il a été suggéré jeudi bien
suggéré puisque le le conseil français
du culte musulman
effectivement je vous rejoins ne pouvons
pas imposer les choses mais nous
souhaitons qu'il puisse y avoir une
structuration de l'organisation de
l'islam au niveau départemental il se
trouve que le nouveau président du
conseil français du culte musulman a
saisi la balle au bond et souhaite
effectivement travailler dans cette
direction
et donc voilà n'imposons rien nous
sommes dans le respect de la loi de 1905
mais nous avons besoin d'avoir un islam
structure et nous avons besoin d'avoir
des partenaires sur le mouillé reprises
une deuxième question jusqu'à nous
aujourd'hui nous menons une commission d
enquête sur la radicalisation islamiste
et nous voyons bien que le problème
n'est pas 1905 mais plutôt 1901
notamment des associations genevoises
associations qui se disent culturel qui
sous couvert son cultuel et donc nous
aurons des propositions fortes j'espère
que vous saurez les entendre et
travailler avec est ce qu'il ya une
ambiguïté sur le statut des associations
7 il peut y avoir une ambiguïté qui ne
nous a pas échappé et dans le cadre de
la réflexion qui est en cours sur un
volet législatif nous aurons
effectivement certain nombre de
propositions là dessus nathalie delattre
vous avez la réponse vous travailler là
dessus donc au sénat et à l'assemblée
nationale pendant ce temps là on parle
beaucoup évidemment de retraite et
stéphane peux vous parler des retraites
des policiers bah oui parce que moi je
viens de passer tout un week-end jour et
nuit dans l'hémicycle sur les retraites
vous avez réussi par vous
personnellement mais le gouvernement a
réussi à mettre toutes les corporations
à dos même celles qui sont les plus
étrangère à la coutume de la grève je
pense aux avocats et à quelques autres
et apparemment même les policiers
puisque il ya eu une réunion le 18
décembre à laquelle vous participiez
avec christophe castaner et l'ensemble
des syndicats
ils sont sortis plutôt rassuré et depuis
c'est la douche froide faire que les
promesses qu'ils avaient cru comprendre
lors de cette réunion du 18 mai sont
notamment sur le fait qu'il y ait un
parallélisme entre les policiers et les
gendarmes
depuis que les gendarmes font été
intégrée au ministère de l'intérieur
apparemment tout ça tout ça
tout ce qui a été dit le 18 décembre ne
se révèle pas vrai les policiers seront
pas traités comme les gendarmes ne
partiront pas à la retraite dans les
mêmes conditions ni au même âge ni avec
les mêmes droits d'emploi la retraite
passé et tous les syndicats de policiers
que j'ai rencontrés comme j'ai rencontré
les syndicats d'autres corporations
seront eux aussi vent debout contre
cette réforme des retraites donc l'autre
question c'est de guevara question c'est
est-ce qu'ils ont raison d'un d'avoir
d'être déçus de la réunion du 18
décembre où est ce que vous pouvez vous
engager à ce que le régime de retraite
des gendarmes sera celui des policiers
et l'un des vingt personnes d'abord il
ya l'engagement enfin à l'issue de la
réunion du 18 décembre effectivement
nous avions discuté avec les policiers
du régime de retraite dans le cadre
d'une nouvelle ce nouveau système
universel puisqu'il bénéficiait
précédemment déjà d'une dérogation d'âge
par un régime spécial il bénéficié le
consejo gassion d'être qu'il conserve
là-dessus il n'y a aucune ambiguïté
simplement est d'ailleurs sa figure à
l'article 36 je crois du projet de loi
donc 7,7
cette dérogation sachant que c'est
renvoyé à une ordonnance a effectivement
meilhan que l'engagement l'engagement
est pris il est fort toutes les missions
qui sont dites aller pour faire simple
on va dire les missions dangereuses
toutes ces missions qui comporte des
sujétions forte et c'est le cas de
l'activité de l'ensemble des policiers
et des gendarmes donc toutes ces
missions ouvriront le bénéfice donc de
l'agression elle même tactique pour les
gendarmes c'est bien ça que c'est bien
là que le bât blesse j'ai ici c'est le
même régime n'y a pas le même fondement
mais c'est exactement le même régime le
ministre de l'intérieur avait bien dit
modulo on exclut en revanche toutes les
missions qui sont dites substituables
c'est à dire qu'ils peuvent être
effectués par des personnels
administratifs on effectuera une
substitution et en police comment
gendarmerie d'agde oui narnia il ya un
sujet sur les personnels de l'institut
de la police scientifique et qui ne sont
pas assimilés alors que leur métier est
un métier de policier avec
des dangers qui sont inhérents à la
fonction mais les syndicats de policiers
constatent néanmoins que avec le flou
qu'il y a dans une loi en vendant des
ordonnances qui seront découvertes le
moment venu
les syndicats de policiers considèrent
tous que le parallélisme des formes
entre gendarmes et policiers ne sera pas
assurée tels que savait que ses rangs
défaveur c'est ça bien sûr c'est en leur
défaveur puisque notamment il ya les
conditions d'âge donné par les
conditions de retraite les conditions
d'emploi poste de retraite fin du cumul
emploi donc ça ne changera pas ce sujet
là c'est autre chose d'abord je vous
réponds je réponds avidement le passé
prend d'abord sur le sur le missionnaire
je vous redis ce que j'ai dit c'est
envoyer à des urgences le principe est
acté laisse les hauts les organisations
syndicales nous les avons régulièrement
avec christophe castaner savent là
dessus qu'ils peuvent nous faire
confiance sur les personnels techniques
et scientifiques c'est une catégorie
actuellement qui ne fait pas partie de
la police active c'est une catégorie de
fonctionnaires administratifs donc à
l'officier par le terrible bénéficiez
pas de dérogation d'âge dont il était
traité comme les fonctionnaires et donc
nous avons souhaité ouvrir un groupe de
travail avec avec elle je les ai reçus
d'ailleurs la semaine dernière pour
réfléchir à ce qu'est leur statut savoir
s'il a évolué ou pas puisque
effectivement pour une partie d'entre
eux ils effectuent des missions sur le
terrain et les relevés dans des
conversations parfois qui sont très
proches de celles de l'exercice de
policiers donc nous avons lancé un
groupe de travail déconnecté d'ailleurs
de la réforme des retraites et qui va
travailler sur ces questions et
d'ailleurs je leur ai écrit mais ils
sont strictement la réponse sera pendant
le débat sur la réforme des retraites où
ce sera après je vous dis ce sujet
déconnecté de la réforme des retraites
c'est un sujet qui vise à travailler sur
le le l'évolution de ce qu'a été la
tension de la cause de leurs moteurs et
qui débouchera sur fait de savoir s'il
faut ou pas des mêmes chances à twitter
d'un rapport à un autre d'une étude rien
d'autre ayotte nathalie delattre
il ya le livre blanc de la sécurité
aussi toujours et encore dans vous
attendez impatiemment les conclusions
oui ça va
puisque deux propositions de loi que
peuvent faire les parlementaires soient
l'assemblée nationale soit au cinéma ou
en amendement de projet de loi du
gouvernement on nous a souvent retoqué
nos textes parce qu'on attendait le
livre blanc de la sécurité sur des
sujets prince des rieurs sur des sujets
précis par exemple nous connaissons le
diagnostic les urgences aussi moi j'ai
participé à deux commission denquête
depuis que je suis élu depuis 2010 est
l'état des forces de sécurité intérieure
où nous avons fait des préconisations
dans un cadre budgétaire sur les heures
supplémentaires qui ne sont pas payés
les logements dégradés ou on voit même
soit en gendarmerie soit des policiers
d'ile-de-france qui dorment dans leur
voiture ou qui colloque à 5 dans vingt
mètres carrés des problèmes de matériel
obsolète puis j'ai participé aussi à la
mission d'information sur les sapeurs
pompiers avec en nouvelles aquitaine un
chiffre qui explose puisque en un an de
2017 à 2018 on ne connaît plus 146%
d'agression vis-à-vis doit donc voilà il
est urgent d'agir
quand est ce que ce livre blanc de la
sécurité intérieure va être débattue
d'abord il est actuellement l'est sujet
du livre blanc sont actuellement en
concertation une concertation très large
qui a été ouverte que le ministre de
l'intérieur a souhaité donc la
concertation se déroule actuellement
nous avons des rapporteurs par un groupe
thématique un groupe sur le continuum de
sécurité vers les partenariats de la
police nationale de gendarmerie
nationale où sont notamment évoquées les
questions des polices municipales il ya
un groupe sur l'organisation de la
police cette volonté que nous avons de
mieux décloisonner l'action de la police
la gendarmerie pour être plus efficace
il ya un groupe sur les nouvelles
technologies qui à usage dont on va
faire demain la reconnaissance faciale
oui non comment dans quelles conditions
quelques adultes tellement large qu'on
se donnait pas positive est publiée
jeudi et puis avant que je mens et puis
effectivement les moyens bénin sydob
pour quand c'est pour corner brook à sa
maintenance et des soeurs d'audition
derrière sur quatre
sami le nombre d'entrées d'être lancée
fin octobre
donc voilà et donc évidemment vous
combien de temps tous les travaux donc
donné combien de temps as besoin
la période postérieure aux municipales
évidemment libres avant ne va pas sortir
avant qu'elle est en période électorale
mais ce sera dans les semaines qui
suivent les élections municipales d'ici
l'été
effectivement et évidemment je serai
prêt d'ici l'été mais il faut de données
ou le montant de concerter d'ailleurs
petit 1,6 pour dire que dans le cadre de
la préparation du livre blanc christophe
castaner a souhaité réunir et venir un
panel de citoyens d'une conférence des
citoyens donc sélectionné d'entre eux
sont libres place et qui est bien
évidemment d'accord tous ceux qui nous
ont fait part de leurs propositions et
leurs observations sur l'action des
forces de sécurité à ce gouvernement qui
a lancé aussi sa police de proximité si
on veut même si vous l'appelez pas comme
ça il s'était fait un peu une question
là dessus
oui enfin sur la police de proximité
puis je fais le lien avec le livre blanc
sur et bien sûr vu la troisième le cnrs
vient de publier une étude
comparative européenne sur les rails la
relation que les populations
entretiennent avec leur police et à
l'occasion de cette étude s'aperçoit que
la france fait partie des pays où les
relations entre la population et sa
police sont les plus dégradées et on
sait tous on sera d'accord je pense là
dessus sur le fait que plus les
relations entre la police et la
population soit apaisée plus la
population reconnaît la légitimité de sa
police et et de ses institutions par à
travers elle alors ma question et je
suis d'un territoire où c'est pas
toujours évident moi je toujours
travaillé le lien police paul du
population depuis je suis né toujours
j'ai toujours été attentif à ne pas
prêter le flanc à des critiques inutiles
pour autant je ne suis pas du tout pour
des relations apaisées avec les voyous
mais je suis pour des relations de
confiance et apaisée avec la population
qui souffre de ces boyaux
or je voulais savoir si c'était vraiment
une des priorités du livre blanc que de
constater ce retard de la france
dégradation des rapports entre sa police
et la population en france et est ce que
c'était un axe une priorité que de
revoir peut-être à travers certaines
doctrines de la sécurité publique dans
les quartiers par exemple des contrôles
d'identité enfin jeu il ya beaucoup de
sujets est ce que c'est un axe du livre
blanc pour vous que de leur en donner
pour leur épreuve donner de la confiance
oui ce sera un axe du livre blanc vous
avez raison que la relation reste bonne
la relation de confiance elle reste
positive mais elle s'est dégradée
c'est indéniable donc évidemment que
depuis longtemps la relation police
population sera au coeur des
propositions du livre blanc mais c'est
déjà au coeur de notre action au travers
de la police de sécurité du quotidien
avec des partenariats forts que nous
souhaitons voir mis en place sur le
terrain avec des effectifs qui vont au
contact de la population
c'est le cas en seine saint denis nous
étions ensemble pour rendre visite à la
brigade à la bst est enfin la brigade de
sécurité territoriale de saint denis qui
patrouillent sur les quartiers à pied
qui a les contacts avec les commerçants
avec les jeunes c'est le rôle aussi des
délégués cohésion police-population ses
réservistes de la police nationale qui
font un travail remarquable auprès
veille avec christophe castaner à
maintenir une réserve qui soit un très
bon niveau en police comment gendarmerie
parce que cette relation de police
population je vous rejoins et vous le
savez nous l'avons vécu dans une autre
vie ensemble dans le département qui
vous est cher c'est quelque chose qui
est fondamentale et oui ce sera
évidemment un axe fort et les quartiers
de reconquête républicaine il y en a
combien ce jour il ya 47 c'est une
ancienne centrale a besoin du
quinquennat ya 20 47 actuelle 60 à la
fin du quinquennat il ce sont des
territoires où comme ailleurs on déploie
la police de sécurité du quotidien ce
partenariat fort cette présence des
effectifs recrutés en nombre pour cette
présence renforcée sur le terrain et
dans ces quartiers de reconquête
républicaine
nous affectons des effectifs
supplémentaires compte tenu du niveau un
moule 50
juste un petit mot parce que j'ai
suffisamment demandé à ce que ça ne soit
pris en compte dans ces quartiers de
reconquête républicaine obtenu de la
part de votre ministère pour ne pas
critiquer le dispositif n'est pas
l'instance à un dispositif d'effectifs
supplémentaires mais c'est la raison
pour laquelle je posais la question sur
le livre blanc la doctrine qui est une
doctrine data de sécurité publique à une
quinzaine d'années depuis que nicolas
sarkozy a rompu spectaculairement avec
la police de proximité alors j'aime pas
les bagarres de mots donc j'utilise un
palais les bagarres de vocables mais on
voit bien qu'il ya un sujet d'effectifs
mais aussi doctrine pour assurer dans
sécurité puis vous avez parfaitement
raison en police nationale comme en
gendarmerie il ya les effectifs ça c'est
sûr il ya le missionnaire il ya la
mission la façon dont on exerce avant
2012 ont les terreaux où on est on est
deux fois la police nationale est
devenue une police d'intervention et les
interviews qui intervenait sur des
incidents et maintenant nous cherchons à
nous et une police de contacts qu'ils
soient présents sur le terrain avec un
rôle répressif c'est indéniable mais il
faut qu'ils aient cette relation avec la
population ces partenariats locaux
c'est bien la direction dans laquelle
nous avons une petite question avant de
passer la parole à la taille de lettres
d'un téléspectateur nathan sur figaro.fr
qui nous écoutent il dit la criminalité
explose à paris mais aussi encore plus
dans une ville comme nantes
qu'est ce que vous comptez faire
monsieur nunez alors ça dépend ce que ce
qu'est ce qu'on appelle la criminalité
je ne sais pas
que j'aie voilà parce que il faut
relativiser
l'explosion de la délinquance comme on
l'entend dire vous savez entre 2017 et
depuis que nous sommes aux affaires et
pour les derniers chiffres de 2019 c'est
les vols violences ont encore baissé de
10% les cambriolages ont baissé de près
de 7%
les vols de véhicules ont baissé de 5%
donc il ya un certain système qui
progresse de manière de la lettre égarée
par exemple ce qui soutient le quotidien
augmente ce qui augment ce sont les
violences physiques aux personnes
notamment les violences gratuites mais
vous savez qu'en grande partie cette
grâce aux politiques que nous menons
pour libérer la parole puisque la moitié
de ces violences physiques ont lieu dans
un cadre familial sont des violences
conjugales ça peut être des violences
également des violences sexuelles et le
fait d'avoir libéré la parole fait que
mécaniquement ces violences augmentent
elles constituent une part non
négligeable des violences ont en tout
cas la circulaire pour nathan nous
luttons de manière déterminée ferme et
résolue contre les violences qui
contrairement à ce qu'on entend de n'ont
pas explosé ces quinze dernières années
vous savez avant 2012 il y avait il y
avait beaucoup plus de vols violences il
y avait beaucoup plus de vols à main
armée donc là il y en avait dix sept
mille en 2010 démarre mais on est tombé
à 9500 la sécurité vous l'avez compris
c'est un des enjeux des municipales ça
c'est clair et net quand on fait les
sondages quand on regarde les sondages
on voit que c'est le premier sujet qui
sort quasiment avec l'environnement
nathalie delattre vous voulez parler des
municipales justement oui tout à fait
parce qu'on en a beaucoup entendu parler
via les médias sur la difficulté de la
fonction d'élu local de mer qui reste
néanmoins l'élu le plus aimé de la
république et le plus apprécié des
français
mais les médias ont aussi parlé de crise
de vocations alors moi si je regarde sa
longue de la gironde terre radicale s'il
en est une
j'invoque la crise de vocation je la
vois moi parce que bon les
dix de moins de 1000 habitants c'est du
panachage mais à partir entre 1000 et
5000 on a moyenne deux listes au dessus
de 5000 trois listes au dessus de 10000
quatre listes minimum pour le giro pour
la gironde
donc voilà je voulais savoir est-ce que
c'est effectivement un constat national
puisque vous devez avoir quand même
quelques remontées statistiques de vos
différentes préfectures même si les
candidatures seront closes le 27 février
à 18 heures je suis 18 heures dans une
préfecture fera 10 et ensuite pourquoi
n'avez vous pas été candidat aux
municipales alors 2 2 versions cd et
d'autres questions qui sont très
différents non mais il a dit alain
gilles répondrai quand même la prodige à
la pompe pour la première donc la
clôture est en jeu dit je ne peux pas
vous donner d'indication chiffrée est ce
que je peux vous dire c'est
qu'effectivement nous craignons pas
collectivement tout le monde craignait
que les maires ne se représente pas que
l'on soit dans certaines communes en mal
de mer au final au final la tendance est
plutôt positif puisque finalement il ya
très peu de deux mères qui se représente
pas beaucoup tous ceux qui ne se
représente pas en trouver des
successeurs de ce point de vue là c'est
plutôt rassurant voilà donc je ne peux
pas vous donner l'information précise
sur les listes déposées puisque la
clôture c'est jeudi comme ça vient
d'être rappelé concernant ma situation
personnelle moi je ne me suis pas
présenté aux élections municipales parce
que je suis tout attaché à ma tâche
auprès de christophe castaner notamment
sur les questions de sécurité qui sont
importants pour notre pays ce qui ne
m'empêche pas et vous l'avez rappelé
fait ça a été rappelé deux créateurs qui
n'empêche pas d'aller d'aller fêter vous
poser la question mais pourquoi est ce
que vous n'avez pas envie d'être mère
quoi c'est ça si je comprends pas c'est
une tâche aux gouvernants bevitori avant
d'être maire
jouer évidemment j'ai recherché le
suffrage à un moment ou un autre puisque
c'est un changement politique cherchant
important chercher chercher le souverain
lors du mandat ce serait mon premier
mandat voilà donc je hais ce serait où
je vois là je vous a vu partout vous
avez gameboy on vous a vu à marseille on
vous avait partout ce serait ou plutôt
voilà donc je n'aurais je ne répond pas
à cette question je suis très concentré
sur un toit mission se pencher sur la
question des tricks doit gérer avec
ainsi de fait un scanner la sécurité la
rose sur l'augmentation du nombre ou pas
de candidature au ministère s qui a une
tendance quand même est-ce qu'il ya plus
- on en est vous y mettez jeu
franchement je ne peux pas répondre à
cette question en plus on est en période
électorale période de réserve je ne peux
pas forcément viendrait de semaine
prochaine a plutôt plus plus comment
vous l'expliquez vous par l'éclatement
de la vie politique depuis les élections
présidentielles de 2017 qui fait que la
gauche est morcelé façon puzzle mais la
droite aussi et il en résulte une
multiplication des listes par la
multiplication des formations politiques
ses fans peuvent ou votre dernière
question voulait rouvrir vous sur les
violences dans les manifs et parce que
je bon vous savez je suis très attaché
au droit de manifester est un droit de
constitutionnel et qui est de plus en
plus difficile je connais plein de
personnes âgées de femmes d'enfants ou
groupe a d'ailleurs qui n'osent plus
aller manifester en raison du climat de
violence qui entoure certaines
manifestations s'étaient un peu moins
vrai sur les manifestations sur les
retraites parce qu'il y avait des
syndicats qui encadraient ces
manifestations mais bon il reste et il
en résulte aussi dans les manifestations
mais aussi en dehors des manifestations
je pense à l'histoire cédric souvient il
en résulte des cds la suite d'une
interdiction générale par une une
interpellation ce chauffeur-livreur
acquérant scooter d'ailleurs avec une
famille extrêmement digne qui a jamais
remis en cause de l'institution
policière dans sa globalité mais qui
veut la vérité vis-à-vis des quatre
policiers qui ont
interpellé lors leur mari ou leur fils
le frère et votre question est donc ma
question est la suivante ce qu'il ya
beaucoup de plus en plus de plaintes à
l'encontre d' acte policiers toujours
très bientôt sur mon vocabulaire sur le
sujet d'actes policiers lisible et est
ce que la france peut rester l'un des
derniers pays développé à ne pas avoir
avoir une structure que l'igpn les
structures de contrôle qu'ils soient et
sont généralement autonomes et qu'ils
puissent pas y avoir pour pour la
transparence pour l' équilibre des
pouvoirs pour la confiance entre la
police et la population une juridiction
autonome pour juger des laurent nunez
des actes de réponse de l'ordre
chaque fois l'inspection générale de la
police nationale il faut bien que vos
téléspectateurs comprennent que cette
inspection chaque fois qu'elle
intervient sur des plaintes donc des
actes violents qui sont jugés comme
n'étant pas proportionnée et donc
susceptibles d'être fautif chaque fois
il que l'igpn est saisie c'est au titre
judiciaire
elle est sous l'autorité d'un parquet
elle est indépendant et cordes avec ses
investigations quelques sur la police
oui mais face à des collègues qui
enquête sur les autres parlez-en avec
les policiers les gp n est assez
intraitable au judiciaire comme comme en
admis mais pour cela dépendrait en ce
moment là pourquoi pas une autorité
indépendante c'est ce qui se fait dans
la plupart des autres pays dans notre
pays la justice est indépendante et
libre armée de la justice allez il faut
que je vois là je pense qu'on peut pas
remettre en cause du gpm
non il n'y a pas de preuve
d'indépendance avec gpn elle-même s'est
elle-même sur la situation sous
l'autorité et pas sur le contrôle c'est
pas un service du ministère de la
justice dit gpn c'est bien le ministère
de l'intérieur
mais c'est bien c'est bien internes à la
police nationale comme tous les services
de police judiciaire
oui ils sont placés sous l'autorité du
procureur de la république et de la
justice sur ce sujet mais je veux juste
rappeler à ces les policiers les
policiers en droit de la fonction
publique c'est 55% des sanctions
administratives également il faut pas
l'oublier
donc voilà on a on a quand même
pas de changement à l'ordre jour pour
l'instant c'est fait peu merci d'être
venu sur ce plateau et merci nathalie
delattre aussi d'être venu sur le
plateau d'auditions publiques et
maintenant il est l'heure d'accueillir
yves thréard du figaro qui va prendre
votre place
bonsoir y vit encore beaucoup de
questions à poser seins nus du rebond
soir mes chevilles question battu
refaire comme elle aida vous êtes issu
de l'ena vous êtes d'ailleurs vous êtes
pour la suppression de l'impôt
je ne suis j'ai fait l'ena oui a été
pour moi une chance formidable ça m'a
permis d'être fonction publique
je crois qu'il ya besoin de
renouvellement dans la formation des
hauts fonctionnaires il ya besoin de
tronc commun il ya besoin d'un alors une
question pour exposer au grand oral de
l'ena c'est quoi séparatistes le
séparatisme ouais c'est partout dans les
quartiers dans des structures
associatives parfois dans un commerce
c'est partout où vous explique que
finalement il ya une loi qui serait
supérieure aux lois de la république
d'accord et qu'il endurait déroulera
sans communautarisme commencé plus
précis que comme une autre c'est plus
précis vous savez on peut on peut avoir
des communautés au sein de la république
qui respecte les règles de la république
française dans quand on est dans une
logique de séparatistes est une logique
politique de séparation finalement de la
nation du vivre ensemble et de la
république je j'exerce un petit droit de
suite tout à l'heure vous avez parlé du
livre ben dans le mont-blanc
il va être question du service des
renseignements de la préfecture de
police de paris qui était mise en cause
dans l'attentât qui a eu lieu à
l'automne
vous vous êtes personnellement pour la
suppression de ce service est ce que
vous allez changer grave je ne suis pas
pour la suppression de la direction du
renseignement de la préfecture de police
de paris à une réflexion
il ya une réflexion qui est en cours je
me suis jamais exprimé en social interio
figaro non julien 6 il ya trois ou
quatre mois
non non de la direction du renseignement
la préfecture de police de paris exerce
sur la sélection
elle exerce des missions elle concourt
notamment la lutte antiterroriste elle
exerce des missions
elle concourt à l'action de la direction
générale de la sécurité intérieure c'est
une direction qui a des relations très
fluide avec la dgsi et je les nageurs
vécu dans ma vie professionnelle des
deux côtés à la fois comme directeur
général de la sécurité intérieure et
puis comme directeur de cabinet du
préfet de police de paris où j'ai eu les
deux casquettes et j'ai eu à à voir
comment fonctionne on s'attend à
maintenir
il ya beaucoup de violence dans cette
campagne
des élections municipales de violence
contre les élus est-ce que c'est plus
que d'habitude
et est ce que ça prend pas une tournure
un peu inquiétant qui encore la
candidate à sa réélection je crois que
c'est amiens qui a été pas physiquement
agressé mais dont le local de campagne a
été complètement dégradée c'est
inquiétant parce que c'est un déni de
démocratie en fait c'est un déni de
démocratie on a un certain nombre de
candidats qui sont empêchés de tenir un
certain nombre de réunions c'est à dire
quelque chose sur la défiance entre le
peuple et la population et ça dit
quelque chose sur un mode d'expression
qui n'est pas acceptable surtout on ne
peut pas accepter qu'on vient me
perturber les voeux d'un élu on peut pas
accepter qu'on empêche une réunion
politique de se tenir parce que dans
notre pays jusqu'à preuve du contraire
ce qui fait la loi démocratique c'est
l'élection c'est la campagne électorale
c'est avoir la possibilité de s'exprimer
et de faire valoir ce droit est ce qu'il
ya donc ça c'est quelque chose qui
contre lequel il faut s'insurger il faut
le condamner de tous bords qu'ils
soutiendraient les fermement l'estomac
aujourd'hui quelques candidats qui sont
sous protection policière
il ya il n'y a pas de candidat sous
protection policière au sens où on
l'entend techniquement mais
christophe castaner l'annoncent à de
nombreuses reprises les élus ont la
possession des contacts téléphoniques
privilégié avec les policiers les
gendarmes de leur ressort
compte tenu des menaces dont ils peuvent
faire l'objet évidemment élections
municipales toujours dont vous aviez
pris une circulaire une circulaire qui
consistait à gommer les étiquettes dans
les villes de moins de 9000 habitants
cette circulaire a été retoqué vous
l'avez vous avez renvoyé une autre
circulaire depuis qu'ils précisent un
peu le oui la règle du jeu
elle a été publié d'ailleurs en quoi il
a été fixé à 350 ans on est revenu sur
le seuil de 2008 il a été tenu compte de
la décision rendue par le brasier
elle était publiée oui c'est vraiment
une série d'erreurs de faire ça non ce
n'était pas une erreur c'était une
demande des associations d'élus c'était
une demande des associations d'élus donc
voilà neuf mille habitants ça
correspondait très correspondait à un
seuil qui existent par ailleurs celui du
mandataire financier celui des dépôts de
comptes de campagne de l'obligation
pardon de dépôt de comptes de campagne
donc c'était pas c'était pas une erreur
c'était une demande des élus le conseil
d'état a considéré que le seuil était
trop élevé dont acte
christophe castaner a pris une autre
circulaire est donc le seuil on est
revenu au seuil de 2008 mais c'était une
demande forte des associations d'élus
des trois mixes président de la
république un des socialistes venus le
seuil de 2008
oui des 3 500 points compteront pas
edouard philippe est candidat dans la
ville du havre où il a déjà été maire
d'ailleurs il faut il faut le rappeler
vous trouvez que c'est bien de se
présenter dans une ville dont et à la
population de laquelle vous dit bah
finalement je me fais lire mais j'irai
pas si j'ai parmi vous il fait il fait
quand c'est nationale il fait campagne
sur un projet avec une équipe
et voilà donc je vois ça me paraît tout
à fait honnête c'est quelque chose qu'il
dit c'est clair et encore une fois il
est d'un fils fait campagne sur son sur
un projet voilà il est engagé dans cette
campagne est naturelle et mourir il
reste pas à wavre après alors écoutez
vous traitez qui continuent à être
premier ministre je bien sûr bien sûr on
travaille on travaille au quotidien avec
edouard philippe
il y aura évidemment il y aura le
modeste secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre de l'intérieur que je suis
n'est pas informée pour celles à ce
point de savoir s'il y aura un
remaniement après essaie de garder le
choc ahmad si j'avais gagné la mairie de
tourcoing il sera obligé d'aller à
turquoise lèche à ussel et les charges
et les fonctions de deux ministres sont
à la disposition du premier ministre et
puis du président de la république qui
tant qu'il y aura nécessairement un
remaniement mais je ne peux absolument
rien vous dire sur ce alors vous n'êtes
pas un droit de suite encore vous n'êtes
pas candidat aux municipales
mais mon petit doigt me dit que vous
réservez pour les régionales vient
beaucoup de ministres à monsieur madame
wargon ce matin disait qu'elle se
réservait peut-être pour les régionales
en île de france et on vous voit bien je
sais pas pourquoi la rumeur circule que
vous pourriez être candidat dans les
bouches du rhône
là il ya beaucoup à dire alors pas car
il ya beaucoup de rumeurs qui circulent
ce n'est pas moins ni moi ni mon
entourage qui est les animaux tant il
est évident qu'il ya des scrutins
importants qui arrivent avant l'élection
présidentielle donc
le parti auquel j'appartiens l'art est
mort à l'occasion donc de proposer un
certain nombre de candidats moi un
moment ou un autre il faudra évidemment
que j'avais affronté le suffrage soit
aux régionales ou peut-être aux
législatives suivantes en tout cas on
verra tout cela pour l'instant moi je
suis à la disposition de la reine et
j'exerce la république et j'exerce mon
bonbon je suis tout tout concentrer sur
l'exercice de mon mandat ministériel à
une petite précision quand on a été pas
ce que vous sortez de la fin vous venez
de la préfectorale vous avez été préfet
du département bouches du rhône on peut
se présenter à un mandat électif dans le
même secteur géographique que là ou
alors j'ai été préfet de police des
bouches du rhône donc c'est le web en
charge les questions de sa qualité et
ses préférés vous avez parfaitement
raison il ya deux préfets dans le
département des bouches du rhône comme
il y en a deux à paris c'est la
particularité de ces deux villes compte
tenu de leur taille et des problèmes de
sécurité qui s'y posent oui je ne suis
pas éligible en je ne suis pas éligible
dans les bouches du rhône avant juin
2020 puisque j'ai quitté mes fonctions
de préfet de police des bouches du rhône
en juin 2017 il ya une inéligibilité de
trois ans et c'est un empêchement pour
les régionales aussi ou pas non ça n'est
pas un empêchement pour les régies
d'accord sachant que les
bouches-du-rhône fondante aka puis monte
le seuil de parenthèse je me permets à
propos d'un sondage qui circulait à
marseille où il y avait un sondage qui
circulait à marseille et qui a été
révélée par des confrères ce matin et
qui frisait oui de france info que
c'était un sondage qui provenaient
des services de police un sondage comme
dans le passé on parlait des sondages
hergé qui était fait et qui donnait
d'ailleurs le rassemblement national en
tête devant le printemps marseillais qui
est une liste dirigée par la france
insoumise ce sondage a une réalité
oh non non ce sondage n'a aucune réalité
donc ça n'est pas juré craché n'y a pas
d'école rôle des services
donc voilà il d'ailleurs dès ce matin le
préfet de police des bouches du rhône et
le préfet des bouches du rhône et l'un
et l'autre dans un communiqué commun
qu'est ce que c'est que cette demande
c'est à dire ça je n'en sais rien il
faut demander les gens demandent est ce
le cas où cette information en tout cas
elle a été démentie et je la démens de
nouveau ce soir évidemment sa vie sur
votre plateau non juste avant dans ce
cas dans ce studio il ya une demande
officielle d'asia bibi vous savez diaby
c'est cette jeune femme chrétienne qui
vivait au pakistan qui a été persécuté
par les autorités et surtout par la
population d'ailleurs pour commencer par
des extrémistes musulmans
est ce qu'elles demandent le droit
d'asile à la france vous trouvez que
c'est normal et je ne je ne connais
faudrait accorder je ne connais pas
cette demande c'est la france beaucoup
d'ail actuel de gens ce sens il a eu la
droite c'est une terre d'accueil ou
voilà on écoute on accueille évidemment
les gens qui sont persécutés dans leur
pays qu'ils sont en besoin de protection
donc voilà je ne connais pas cette
demande je n'en ai pas connaissance d'un
crash mais je vous dirais des des
sottises en tout cas nous sommes une
terre d'accueil et tous les gens qui
sont persécutés et un autre garçon
réserve bien évidemment d'une analyse de
l'ofpra l'office français de protection
des réfugiés et apatrides l'asile est
évidemment accordée aux personnes qui
sont besoin de protection comme piotr
paszkowski
son clavier il a eu le sentiment là il
est les motifs de remise en question de
la delà du statut de réfugié là son
émission très précis sont prévus sont
sont très restrictifs mais un statut de
réfugié peut toujours évidemment être
revenir toujours alors qu'il irait
conditions il ya 3 il ya des conditions
très précises de remise en cause crêpes
contre l'humanité qui sont plutôt pour
des faits de guerre peu qu'ils sont
plutôt pour des faits graves
mais voilà donc pourquoi parce qu'il
n'ya pas de faire voilà il faudrait
qu'on regarde ça d'un peu plus près mais
je ne crois pas que ce soit le cas je me
sens pas bien joué julian assange qui
est l'auteur dé wikileaks c'est à dire 2
millions de dhs informations qui ont
circulé sur des correspondances
diplomatiques
parfois gênante d'ailleurs pour les
états j'ai la charge de bandeaux si
l'asile en france d'accorder son avocat
a surtout eric dupond moretti
alors non je je je réserve
en tout cas je vois là je réserve ma
réponse en tout cas je n'ai pas
connaissance de 7,2 mais vous avez vous
avez votre mot à dire que vous en tant
que présent vous jure quelqu'un qui a
fait fuiter des des secrets d'état c'est
pas tellement faux pas sont pas
l'accueillir en france voilà donc
écouter le lit a déclaré rossi qui se
voit là avec en halo froid qui se
prononce je vois là sur ces deux
dossiers à peu délité un précédent de
madame celui alors dernier j'ai encore
question je crois bon 30 secondes 30
secondes en tout cas nous on a compris
que le quinquennat la deuxième partie du
quinquennat serait consacrée aux
régalien et à la défense de
l'environnement l'écologie sur le
régalien qu'est ce que vous allez faire
de plus mais sur le régalien
c'est l'action qu'on mène contre le
séparatisme d'abord poursuivre tout ce
que nous faisons sur la lutte
antiterroriste
ce que nous faisons sur la lutte contre
la délinquance pour faire continuer à
faire baisser les violences continuent à
faire baisser les violences
et puis bien sûr l'action résolue que
nous allons engager à lutter contre le
séparatisme qui est totalement inédite
beaucoup ont oublié beaucoup le critique
cette action qui trouvent qu'on ne va
pas assez loin ils ont la mémoire très
courte puisque alors à leur époque
rien n'avait été fait tourner ça fera
partie de la campagne de la
présidentielle prochaine si vous avez
bien que les régionales peut-être aussi
d'ailleurs merci mais il repart c'est la
fin de votre audition d'eric laurent de
neste merci d'avoir accepté la
résiliation
vous pouvez retrouver cette émission sur
fedora yahlive les comptes twitter de
lcp public sénat et auditions publiques
revient bien lundi prochain à 19h en
direct bonne soirée